uh what i can tell you is that uh all  the guidelines were observed continue to  be observed and what i can also tell you  is that we're getting on with the job as  we have been uh throughout of dealing  with the the priorities of the people  particularly fighting crime so is it was  it was it a party where the guidelines  were followed or was it not a party  i can tell you that the guidelines were  followed at all times well did you  investigate that yourself have you  satisfied yourself i have satisfied  myself that the guidelines were followed  at all times and what i can also tell  you is that we're focusing on the issues  that matter to uh me above all and that  is fighting crime and i believe those  are the things that matter also to the  british public